good afternoon welcome I'm Richard prohm
in the department of ecology and
evolutionary biology and director of the
Frankie program in science and the
humanities welcome to this FPS lecture
and discussion I think the first thing I
like to do is talk about what's
mentioned some things that are upcoming
this is our first event of the of the
semester but on Tuesday October 25 will
be hosting a lecture by Frederick kak
from the musée de que bevarly and in
Paris he's an anthropologist that will
be speaking about avian flu in Asia so
anthropologists on flu and then in
Wednesday November 30th will have a
lecture by dr. Laura Martin of Harvard
on such merciless war and extermination
from Indian reservations to nature
reservations about the history of
transition to natural lands in Native
American communities we also are still
working on nailing down a date for
Andrea wolf the author of a recent
biography of Alexander von Humboldt we
hope to have that in middle November of
talk about her book the invention of
nature but today we will be presenting
or a series of speakers on the topic of
the evolutionary roots of female orgasm
and to show that evolutionary biologists
can learn from the humanities we have a
new format we will have a diverse set of
people instead of the traditional single
talk we'll have a tag team talk from our
presenters and then a commentary
discussion by another another guest so
will the talk will be given by mahila
Pavich ebb and Gunter vagner and then
that we followed by commentary and and
by Elizabeth Lloyd I will introduce our
speakers and then Elizabeth when when
when she when she comes ok so the
speakers are mahila Pavich evolution
assistant professor of at the university
of cincinnati department
pediatrics she received her PhD at the
University of Vienna did postdocs in at
with Jim chevre at Washington University
in st. Louis and Tom Hanson at at Oslo
and she is now an assistant professor in
in pediatrics and has done a diversity
of work on genetics and development and
evolutionary biology at this at this
nexus the other presenter is Gunther
vogner who is the Allison Richards
professor of ecology and evolutionary
biology here at at Yale in the
department of ecology and evolutionary
biology and in the West West Campus
Institute for systems biology he has
also recently appointed a department of
obstetrics gynecology and reproductive
sciences at yale and also adjunct
professor of obstetrics and gynecology
at Wayne State this is a new new
directions for his research so without
further ado I welcome gooder and it's
going to start the beginning of the talk
let's welcome
okay thank you Rick and I want to start
and for motivating why we are here and
giving this talk so as I understand it
Frankie program in science and
humanities that's the task of actually
breaching the ever widening gulf between
the humanities and the sciences and I
think there is no other area where you
know humanity since the science is in
particular biology / led more than in
the area of human sexuality to my
untrained ears and eyes a lot of the you
know poetic artistic and musical
production is in one way or the other
are connected to human sexuality and of
course sexuality is also rooted in our
biological nature and so it it's also a
subject matter for biologists and I
think for that reason I am particularly
grateful for the opportunity that we
could talk here about our ideas on
female orgasm and how that reflects on
how we understand they would usually in
general it turns out to be actually one
of the best examples of how different
perspectives to evolution relate so
thank you Rick for the opportunity to
speak here and Gary and the Frank is in
particular for making this whole program
possible so here is our talk Michaela
and I will talk about the evolutionary
roots of female workers and just to give
you an idea I will give you a little bit
introduction the background why is theme
of the workers mystery at least for
biologists modes of explanation of
evolution or devolution of biology that
sort of relevant to understand why we
consider the mystery and then the actual
court of scientific facts will be
presented by michaela
we were actually now calling our model
divestiture homolog model of female
orgasm we'll talk about the physiology
and the evolutionary homologues of
female orgasm it then in the end I will
sort of make say a few words about what
it all means and sort of in a broader
sense before they then get their
presentation by Lisa Lloyd so in order
to set this up there are two facts that
we are many people agree on and they
also sort of encapsulate why there is a
problem in the explanation of female
orgasm and that's all inspired and are
documented by lizards book on the the
case of the female orgasm first of all
female orgasm has no necessary role in
reproduction and also it's not strongly
linked to intercourse and that actually
this problem the first one is already
going back to the very beginning of
biological thinking all the way to RS
total and you can find two areas in this
writing where he reflects on the
function or non-functional female August
the one hence there is this book called
the generation of animals that he
basically argues that and the obvious
fact that female orgasm is not necessary
for a woman to have a baby so therefore
there is no necessary reproductive
function of female workers on the other
hand there is the book 10 in the
historian imodium where he sort of
switches his position and he thinks for
theorizes that you know female
secretions and male secretions need to
mix in order for fertilization to happen
and therefore you get female secretions
in orgasm as you get mail secretions and
actually he reversed this opinion here
it's not entirely clear whether both
books were actually both written by
Aristotle and might reflect different
authors but that's at least the way it
came down to us and the second point I
know that Lisa will talk about it works
extensively here's a quote out of the
book that says out of 27 independent
studies the rate of woman who never
never have orgasms with intercourse
range from two percent for the three
percent with a mean of 12.5 percent
quite substantial a number of women
apparently report never having had
workers during intercourse but whether
ology this means how do we explain the
existence of a trade that the one hand
has no obvious function and is highly
variable in the occurrence oh it's not
linked to some particular other thing
that's going on now at this point I
would want to make a very short sketch
of different modes of evolutionary
thinking that are relevant to the
question of how we try to explain the
existence of any trade there are
basically two forms of thinking the
bonus could be called functionalism the
other one structuralism if you want to
encapsulate what functionalism means is
it's basically the idea that the
functional role of a trade equals the
reason for its existence and the idea is
that biological traits are brought about
by into existence by natural selection
to perform a particular function so if
you think that that's the main way to
explain the existence of the thing you
have to find the puncture first and then
you have basically explained what what
what the trade is about on the other
hand structuralism is a the notion that
evolution is actually the result of a
complex history of opportunities and
constraints and the various choices
quote-unquote that were made in the
natural history of this trade explains
where it ended up let me say that there
certainly cases of functionalism really
works right for instance you can make a
plausible argument that the white fear
of the polar bear is explained by
camouflage
in the snowy environment and maybe also
with respect to heat radiation that is
minimized by a white coat compared to a
black or a brown coat so that's a that's
a plausible story are not going to
challenge that and other ones are you
know explanation of where is big shapes
and in the Darwin finches for instance
of Pete and Rosemary grant spent the
whole life more or less explaining and
reconstruction how dramatic changes and
seat availability leads to the evolution
of different big depths and shapes and
so on okay so that function this works
but functionalism doesn't work always
right there are cases where
functionalist explanation just don't get
us anywhere obviously feathers we find
in periods lots of birds fly and they
needs the deities feathers to fly so
does this mean that flight explains the
origin of of feathers first of all there
are other ways of flying right so so
flight itself does not uniquely explain
the origin of our feathers and my friend
says no way you can explain the origin
of feathers primarily because in order
to come up with a complex structure like
feathers it has to go through a number
of stages one necessary before the other
need of this these early stages can be
useful in flight so it is actually a
history of of events where you know
there was a hollow tube evolving and
then the bar breaches and so on its own
i don't want to go into the main point
is that the first stage of that
evolution of the feather has certainly
nothing to do with this flight so flight
doesn't explain the origin of pedal or
feathers so we summarize this
functionalism is most successful
explaining modifications and existing
structures recent modifications I would
say like shape of Peaks or via color and
it's less successful in the origin of
complex normal structures okay
so how does structuralism work and this
is less easy to sort of encapsulate in a
small st. Ann's it the way I think about
it is that you have to find homologues
of the character across species so that
you have a change of actually
understanding the history then you try
to enter faint the developmental of
physiological core underlying all these
realizations of the character then from
that we can ask try to understand the
origin of this physiological core and
then hopefully also understand that
evolved ability and the constraint of
the character that it brings with it so
I have two two slides or three slides on
homology because they sort of take the
core concept that carries them structure
this approach so at the most elementary
level homology is a very simple concept
right you have two organisms and their
corresponding body parts that's what it
is about but it gets complicated if you
actually do it in a more detailed way
and don't want to go into too much
detail here because you don't have the
time just want to quote a classical
definition they make a homologue is the
same organ different animals under every
variety of form and function that will
be important for our model maybe the
point that homology is not identity in
the sense of complete you know detailed
similarity but it is the sameness in a
way that I cannot explain here under
every variety of form upon or in other
words homologs change the function
they've changed a shape that and so
homologues change and therefore are not
absolutely identical so was dead I want
to hand over to Michaela and she will
explain the science behind his paper
that we published this summer and where
we proposed this model
sorry it's a good afternoon thank you
for coming and really thank you for the
friendly program for organizing this i
think it's a it's a very important topic
that has probably had really not enough
attention that's why we as you will see
we have so many questions still that are
open so let me I think I will start with
them with the core idea first and then
go into the biology so that you can
better understand why we come up with
this with this claim so our claim is
that the female orgasm is a homologue of
the of the neuroendocrine reflects that
actually induces ovulation in those
species that need ovulation to be
induced by population and in a second
part we think that this function of the
function of this reflects was lost in
those species which evolved spontaneous
ovulation which is what we have for
instance and just to give you the the
background of course of why we why we
think it's this way this is the ovarian
cycle this is at the very basis of the
of the female reproduction reproduction
and what it shows is really the release
of the of the eggs from the ovary that
happens if in humans spontaneously and
what you see here is really the simply
the oops sorry the the ovary with the
during the fully coated genesis follicle
actually has the egg in it release into
the female reproductive tract which is
what we call a relation and then the the
this volatile turns into corpus luteum
which is a very ephemeral gland that
produces a lot of progesterone for a
while and after that the hope the whole
thing starts again however not not all
of the animals how
this way some of some of them actually
really need induction and this induction
can be environmental it can be by
copulation to go a little bit more into
detail of how this whole thing is
regulated in species that have
spontaneous of relation and it will
really be a little bit detail is it's
really regulated in the axis between the
pituitary which is in the brain and the
ovary and what happens is that the ovary
produces as as they as the follicle
growth produces estrogen generates the
signal in the in the pituitary that is
that is triggered by the by the nura
secretion ganado gonadotropin-releasing
hormone get secreted here and triggers
the secretion of the luteinizing hormone
and and follicular stimulation hormone
which cause then the the ovulation this
is then reflected also in the way how
our our hormones are cycling in the
during the month so that this would be
the the peak of them of the luteinizing
hormone and then you see the peak of the
of the progesterone following from the
from the corpus luteum and the estrogen
preceding it a little bit okay so this
is this is how it works in in
spontaneous of ovulation in basically
that works a little bit different in in
copulation induced ovulate errs in that
the same core is working but what is
inducing it is really the the neural
impulse that comes from from tactile
stimulation of that of the reproductive
tract so this is this is the core and
this is the stimulation
and then we have the same the same
secretion of the hormones we see that
this happens really really fast so even
even within a half this is this is the
dumb luteinizing hormone in the in
rabbit and if the copulation happens
here the the peak of the of the hormone
can be detected in serum within half an
hour which is really a fast reaction so
what I think is not at all trivial is
that even though this is the system that
we are using orgasm actually projects
neroli into the pituitary not only but
it does and and what you see here it
triggers the secretion of oxytocin of
luteinizing hormone and of prolactin and
let us just look at the at at the levels
and you will see that the level of
oxytocin is not the peak is not
particularly high so this is females and
males and and orgasm it's about this
site and this experiments are done on
masturbating individuals the same with
with a luteinizing hormone and this is
only only done in in females you see the
peak it seems it seems there is a big
it's not very high however prolactin
picus is enormous and what you see here
our results of the experiments done on
on males and females and they were done
on coitus induced orgasm as well as on
masturbation induced orgasm and you see
the old gasm happening here where the
arrow is I'm sorry for the not optimal
resolution here but but it it increases
immensely what you might misunderstand
if you don't see the scale is that the
levels in females are much much higher
than the levels in males and if we if we
show this really properly on the same
scale
looks like this so it's it's really very
different the same thing has been has
been shown in a different way with PET
scans where they've shown that that
female orgasm but not male orgasm
actually trigger pituitary it's
important to know that all of the
hormones that we've seen that are that
are actually being secreted have along
with many other functions as the
hormones usually have they all have the
function in in the in the early ovarian
cycle so in the early post post
ovulatory face and and prolactin
actually husband has been founded in
women the decrease of physiological
levels of prolactin actually prolonged
the luteal phase of the children the
luteal phase of them ovarian cycle and
the same with oxytocin has a functions
in supporting gluttonous ation and it
also has a probably ancestral function
in oviedo contractions that actually
transport the egg damba oviduct so I
think that that you know this this um
these observations are really really not
trivial in the sense that if we if we
think of a female orgasm as we do very
often in human females of the of the
much more emotional part of it there
would be the part of the brain that this
is causing that would be the limbic Oh
part limit of system and and not not
really the the pituitary and another
thing that that is it is important with
this is that the the search is really
very very strongly female biased so
there is something about the female
function of it
so given given our our thesis we made we
made with that relation we made two
predictions and so if if the female
orgasm is really the homologue of them
of the neuroendocrine reflects then we
would we would we would really expect
that induce ovulation would have to
predate the older than the than the
spontaneous ovulation and secondly if
the dysfunction has been lost then the
change of genital Anatomy might might
reflect this and the way we the way we
went about this was was twofold so we
started with with trying to trace the
characters on the phylogenetic tree so
just just a very short intro enter into
phylogenetic tree what you see here are
practically relationships between the
single species you can think of
phylogenetic trees in the same way as
you think about the the pedigrees for
instance so the closer the closer to
individual the closer the connections
the the more the more related the
species are these trees are put together
in the by independent information and
then the then the trait that we are we
are mapping on to them so they are put
together by information about molecular
similarity genetic similarity and the
and the fossil record and what we what
we map here here onto this tree is the
male induced of elation and spontaneous
of relation so which species are
represented by by which character which
characters is common in which species
and what we can infer from here is that
the common ancestor here of the of the
mammals and kept amor su pills here so
the placental mammals is actually the
green one so the male induce ovulation
this is this is why we are we are we are
concluding that the
mainly juice ovulation is actually
predating the spontaneous of relation
the second part is is it's an overview
study of the of the female genital
anatomy and I must say i was i was very
surprised how hard it was to find
information its you wouldn't believe it
most of the most of the anatomy books
would would treat the mail system and
then comment at the differences that's
that's as far as it goes usually and and
so one point that i want to make here on
the under human female genital anatomies
just simply the number of of orifices so
we have we have recto we have vaginal
canal and then we have we throw so the
opening of the of the bladder and this
is how i'll be showing it so it's it's
really the rig rectum vagina and the
bladder and the glans clitoris is
usually associated with the opening of
the wreath through so as you can see
here in primates and road that rodents
it's actually at a distance from from
vaginal opening this is not at all the
same in in all species and if we kind of
use a little bit course classification
we can see three different types one is
one isn't a little bit more basil
lineages have the cloaca where all of
the openings actually empty into so we
have rectum we have urogenital sinus
which is a co fluence practically of the
of the bladder and they and a vagina we
have then this intermediate form where
where the rectum is already already
separated but we still have the
urogenital sinus this is very very
spread this is very widely spread
situation and you see the bladder still
opening into into your genital sinus and
then the one that I've mentioned before
one thing to mention is
that to note here is that with this
change in in anatomy the position of the
of the glans clitoris changes so it kind
of travels from being very much inside
to being very much outside of the of the
vaginal canal and if we then go back and
map the this distribution of the
position of the clitoris onto the onto
the fellow Johnny and this is the lower
part and then look at the at the
distribution of ovulation of the types
of population we see that there is a
there is a pretty good correlation
between the trees meaning that most of
the animals that have spontaneous of
relation have clitoris outside and
animals that have have induced ovulation
have clitoris on the inside with of
course number some variation I must also
say it's it's it's a little bit hard to
get the very reliable data to every
single for every single species species
in the field are hard to determine what
their kind of population is so one thing
to say to that as you know when Gunther
started before talking about the the the
absence of orgasm and so many women it's
you can easily see its evolution it's
not pathology clitoris is on the outside
so it's maybe not so so so surprising
that the orgasm is is in the in the
normal intercourse is actually rare or
rarer than one would expect so this is
our this is really our model of
evolution of ovulation with i mentioned
environmental signal inducing ovulation
for instance in fishes and and frogs and
and some remnant of it also also later
where the oblation can be induced by
temperature can be induced induced by
buy photo period then we have this this
situation where copulation is the in is
what induces of elation
and therefore ovulation and population
are very strongly coupled and then we
have this this third case that that we
are talking about with with um with
spontaneous ovulation were the
copulation and and ovulation gets get
decoupled but of course every I think
average every hypothesis the real value
of every hypothesis is what it does then
for our questions or for for our search
for for new knowledge and and we are now
in the advantage that that we have had a
lot of discussions after this paper came
came out and we have a lot of a lot of
questions have crystallized and one
thing that we often get asked this is so
what drove the coevolution of anatomy
and and a type of ovulation right and
and and it's it's it's really it's
really interesting to think about what
it could be you could think about
spontaneous ovulation evolving first and
then maybe the the signal would be would
actually be disadvantageous because it
was interrupt it would interrupt the
normal cycle it might interrupt the
pregnancy if if the female ovulated in
the middle you could think about the
mattamy going first and followed by the
by the by the spontaneous of relation of
course if once the signal becomes
unreliable that might be the case that
it's it's necessary but i think that the
third one is the one that I'm excited
about about looking into and this is the
simultaneous change we know that that
the development of the of the female and
male actually genitals is very very
strongly affected by the by the hormonal
environment of the mom so if that
changes the the genital morphology might
change just along the way would be
interesting to see
another question is of course and and
that's that um those are many comments
that that we have gotten is about the
other aspects of really female orgasm
and how do they play into into a picture
so human female and I think that that's
that's really the topic that that binds
then back to what country has already
started to talk about namely the
homology identifying the homologous
aspect and that's for us was the pasta
and the chronology of a trade across
species is necessary to explain its
origin but it's very important to to
understand that this model does not even
aspire to explain all the aspects of the
of the female orgasm there are many more
in humans probably that that that
evolved that that cannot be explained by
by by this model and so one of the one
of them is of course looking into the
into other Knick neurological aspects
and into into really what is causing
this connection to the to the pituitary
in female orgasm we know very little
about it but some like some some some we
do we know about the female orgasm that
and most of the research has actually
been done on this part is that it
triggers limbic system so all the
emotional parts all the all the other
parts of it is triggered we know a
little bit less about what it what is
actually triggering the pituitary but
there seems to be a negative effect of
the of the North noradrenergic
connections that that really inhibit the
the secretion of the dopamine so
dopamine get secreted into the same part
as the as the going to open releasing
hormone does and it suppresses the
production of prolactin this is probably
the reason why we get this prolactin
peak after the orgasm the the
norepinephrine
actually actually suppresses the
suppressor of the prolactin so we know
some some part of it we know we know for
the induced ovulation probably a
different part of it we know we know
that it's also norepinephrine that works
through the through the newer secretory
other neurosecretory cells that generate
this this pool of kannada tropin
releasing hormone so we see we have we
have similarities but the questions
about limbic systems here and and the
question about the direct effects on
pituitary here just haven't been been
answered yet so we in in other words the
way of gonna end this is really to say
it's we don't have the information so
far to answer the question to what
extent other aspects have been are
really similar but to some extent we
don't even expect them to be because a
lot of what was common in the evolution
between the between the two the two
traits the induction of the relation and
they and the female orgasm a lot of that
has been has been changed in the
interspecies Pacific modification so
with that I'm going back to to your
slides
so now I feel compelled to see a little
bit that goes beyond the strict biology
because we are in the witness you manage
the center and so the two aspects are
going to make sure i know one of which
is one that Mikhail already mentioned
and no Lisa will talk more extensively
about it maybe what it means all this in
the area for the for the understanding
of female sexuality in particular the
variability of female orgasm in context
of cooperation and the other I think
also sort of philosophically interesting
questions how should we think about the
part of the penal physiology that there
seems to be useless in in a certain
sense right so so there has already said
I can just quickly evolutionary changes
today are not to meet at X of the
external genitalia of females makes
copulation use to orgasm less likely
because of the removal of the clitoris
from the copulatory organ which means
that the leg of coit orgasm is a natural
consequence of evolution right so that
is something we really need to reflect
on and the Questor the other thing is so
what is sort of positive value and
statements that are attached to
apparently useless biological traits and
here they give a trigger warning maybe
someone would be offended by that but my
thesis is that female oguz if you think
of it as something that got liberated
from its biological necessities is
actually a spirit elect and we are not
the first ones who actually proposed
this we actually michaela found their
growth
a blog by slawek Dziedzic famous
philosopher from Slovenia but a
coincidence and he wrote in this very
blog entry that was in the reaction to
Lisa's book in 2005 is that the very
super fluidity of female orgasm makes it
all the more spiritual right we also got
after our paper was published and
emailed by from Tony Bentley who is a
dancer in the and writer and she got
famous for a book also published in 2005
called surrender and I cannot actually
quote from there but you know one thing
that was possible to pick booty areas
beyond control there's God and of course
she meant surrender in sexual
intercourse sexual encounter so I think
that is a perspective that is not only
shared among us but actually other
people independently and before have
already thought along those same lines
that you know decoupling a biological
trait from its utilitarian necessities
actually make them in a way much more
interesting in a way that it is a
spiritual if you want we also try to
make a point independent of our own
paper in an editorial that should be
published in the same issue as to our
biology paper where we write that one
can think of female orgasm as a form of
art entering only to itself rather than
to some utilitarian necessities probably
the most intimate form of art for an
audience of one or two and with that I
want to thank you all for your attention
and patience and acknowledge no funding
for this particular type of research
thank you very much
desktop
great well my pleasure to introduce our
commentator today Elizabeth Lloyd is the
Arnold and Maxine tennis chair of
history and philosophy of science at the
University of Indiana she's also
professor adjunct professor in the
Department of Philosophy an affiliated
faculty scholar at the Kinsey Institute
for the Study of sexual research in
gender in sex gender and reproduction
and adjunct faculty at the senator or
the integrative the center for the
integrative study of animal behavior at
Indiana a professor lloyds studied at
university of colorado at harvard and in
princeton and she has done a diversity
of work on evolutionary psychology on
levels of selection in evolutionary
biology on the intellectual structure of
a blue here about itself and more
recently on adaptation ism but her role
in this work has been afforded by her
publication both her early influence on
literature by Steven gold and others but
her publication in 2005 of the case of
the female orgasm which good Tara and
Michaela have already mentioned that
book made a incredibly strong critique
of the adaptation 'used explanations of
orgasm and proposed and furthered the
by-product or a fortunate accident
perspective so for her commentary
Elizabeth
oh you're sorry it's already do I do
this okay thank you thank you very much
for inviting me to comment I'm delighted
to be here and it's a privilege to be
commenting on such interesting work I'm
going to start by briefly reviewing some
of the most prominent theories of the
evolution of female orgasm and I'm going
to mention some evidence that's
pertinent to the debate before getting
into a detailed discussion of today's
hypothesis this question about orgasm is
one with consequences as has already
been mentioned for example an
evolutionary account of female orgasm is
used to underpin the notion of a normal
function of female orgasm for the
Diagnostic and Statistical Manual of the
psychiatric profession is yes m4 in
Sunnah dsm-5 by which sexual disorders
are diagnosed but an evolutionary
science there is no single accepted
evolutionary count of female orgasm and
thus no notion of its normal function if
it has any at all in mind 2005 book the
kids of the female orgasm I've gave
detailed examinations of all 21
published theories of how the trade had
evolved and all but one of them claim
that evolution was a claim that orgasm
was an evolutionary adaptation but
examine this curve this curve is
presented represented by an x axis of
the overall orgasmic performance with
heterosexual oops heterosexual
intercourse and
the y-axis represents the frequency
frequency to which women achieve that
orgasm it's a study of twins bike item
day would and colleagues note that only
about 13% of women actually always have
orgasm from intercourse and roughly a
third of women rarely or never do but
not very way to thirteen percent of
women actually this is not the right
representation of the data thirteen
percent of women never have orgasm by
any means at all and these results
conform well to mice with my study of 32
studies spanning 74 years as you can see
this curve is basically flat simple
selective forces though produce peaks in
adoptive curved and as more and more of
the organisms in a population are
selected to have the desirable form of a
trade which may be up here somewhere if
there's no selection acting on a
particular trait we may expect to see
exactly what we get in the female orgasm
case a fairly flat distribution across
all four possible forms of the trade
from highly orgasmic to inaudible cat
orgasmic at all the fact that women vary
so widely in their orgasmic performance
provides very suggestive evidence that
every one of the selective explanations
offered so far for female orgasm no
matter what their details art is wrong
each one of these adaptive explanations
offered so far except one that I'll tell
you about predicts a peak in this curve
but as you can see there are no real
peaks and nearly every one of the
selective and adaptive explanations for
female orgasm is undermined by the data
from sexology when we think about female
orgasm at first it seems perfectly
obvious that the trait is
adaptation common sense tells us that
women who have orgasms will want to have
more intercourse and more intercourse
leads to more babies those female orgasm
seems to be an adaptation evolved
through natural selection which explains
his presence in the population
unfortunately the basic premise of this
explanation is not true women who have
more orgasms do not have morning of
course as alfred kinsey anas colleagues
established in the 1950s and has been
reconfirmed sense more importantly women
who have more orgasms do not seem to
have more babies and women who are more
orgasmic do not have more desire to have
sex there is no correlation between how
orgasmic a woman is and her having or
wanting to have intercourse so finally
zgn scintilla found a flat zero genetic
correlation between or desmond fitness
not even a tiny suggestion of a
connection between orgasm and fitness
nothing
but also let's compare and really
consider the adoptive parent approaches
these are variants of desmond morris
original pair-bond explanation and they
accounted for ten of the explanations
I've investigated in my book on such an
account the female orgasm evolved to
reward the woman for participating in
frequent intercourse which itself was a
way to quote cement the pair bond and
the pair bond is a more or less
exclusive relationship with one male
claimed to be important for raising
children and for participating in the
raising of children and providing
protection and sustenance for the woman
and child in them orgasms reoccur
reliably as her reward for participating
in intercourse which in turn occurs
frequently to help cement the pair bond
so here's the status of the evidence for
the pair bond account because this
assumption or requirement that female
orgasms occurred totally reliably
without intercourse as her reward there
are grave evidential problems with the
ten proposed perigo pair bond accounts
they're not compatible with a sex
research either published at that time
or since women do not reliably have
orgasm with intercourse as we've said
and as most adults know so what drove
the scientists into these flawed
explanations my conclusion is that there
was an unconscious male centered bias
operating for throughout the
explanations female response to
intercourse was assumed to be the same
as male response to end of course this
unfounded and unconscious assumption has
led many researchers to pursue misguided
theories male centered bias involves
looking at things from an exclusively
male point of view and subsequently
neglecting a distinct treatment of a few
point of view in these scenarios and
autonomous are distinctly different
female sexuality which emerged so
clearly from the sex research is ignored
despite its height visibility at the
time a non-adaptive evolutionary
explanation of female orgasm was offered
by anthropologist on assignments in 1979
the basic idea is based on the
development of the embryo in males
orgasms are adaptations they were
actively selective for by females get
them for free just like males good
nipples for free not you know we got the
better end of that deal in males orgasms
are adaptations so this sort of
explanation is called developmental or
non-adaptive if you know orgasm is seen
as a by-product or of selection on male
orgasm it's easier to understand with a
picture so sorry about the explicit
nature of the picture I couldn't help it
here here you see the early embryos
genital typical at the top which turns
into the penis in the mate wait okay
here we go the penis in the mail and the
clitoris and the female note how hard it
is to tell the difference between these
two these organs with common
embryological origins are homologs which
is what the words previously discussed
the tissues involved in orgasm for males
and females are also homologs including
nerve tissues erectile tissues and
muscle fibers thus females get the
functioning orgasmic tissues through
this embryological connection and are
often capable of having orgasms under
the right conditions a rhythmic
stimulation so there is a variety of
evidence supporting this by-product
account
orgasm although it's encountered a great
deal of resistance and I think that part
of this is surely the byproduct named
feminist sex guru suze bright commented
that it made female orgasm sound like a
can of spam so I'm in the process of
renaming it the fantastic bonus account
so Simon's a court so I means account of
course what with the data available
about human sexuality strikingly females
masturbate through the direct
stimulation of the clitoris the
homologous organ to the penis and not
through simulating and of course just as
we would expect on the by-product
account this theory also allows us to
make sense of the otherwise puzzling
data on the in frequency with which
women experience orgasm with unassisted
or what I call no hands intercourse
Simon's thesis general thesis is also
sported by the non-human primate
evidence female some tail macaques have
been shown to have orgasms by hardwiring
them up and to detect the orgasmic
response showing that they have the
distinctive contractions and other
bodily markers characteristic of orgasm
note the assignments and I are not
denying that the clitoris as an
organization almost certainly has been
under selection pressure because it aids
the female in sexual excitement and
induces and prepares her to have go out
and have intercourse but this reasoning
does not extend to the use of these same
tissues for female orgasm orgasm is a
special reflex that with some sometimes
results from clitoral and genital
segments general sexual excitement and a
special reflexive orgasm are easily
distinguished by most one
and just as easily distinguished by
natural selection here is a summary of
the evidence for the byproduct bonus
account but many evolutionists
nevertheless believe despite this
evidence that female orgasm is an
adaptation and most rely on a female
choice theory of the trait which is the
only adaptive account that's compatible
with the flat curve distribution let's
take a look at the evidence for this
female choice model the current adaptive
model being promoted today the basic
idea is that the female will mate with
more than one male over a short period
of time and have orgasm preferentially
with the higher quality males the
assumption here is that orgasm is
accompanied by a mechanism of uterine
upset sorry about the name that makes it
more likely that female will be
fertilized by the higher quality male
thus leading her to higher fitness thus
the orgasmic women are required to
respond conditionally yes to orgasm with
higher quality meals and no to orgasm
with lower quality males so this type of
female choice selection scenario can
theoretically produce a flat curve of
trait variation like the one we see for
orgasm but only provided that the force
of selection is strong so I'd like to
draw your attention to two aspects of
this adaptive model first while the
mechanism of uterine up suck is commonly
assumed by the female choice model and
has recently been declared devoid of
evidence supporting evidence by a taut
specialist in female sexuality and
orgasm so there is actually evidence
against uterine up suck through an old
experiment the absurd hypothesis is
nevertheless very widely believed by way
people thanks to a deceptively NER
created video on a nature show there are
also new data that they're directly on
the feasibility of another key mechanism
at stake in the female choice hypothesis
the conditionality of the female orgasm
with which is important to the
interesting hypothesis under
consideration today in a study published
by neurophysiologist Tim Waller and I
those women who reported orgasm with
intercourse had significantly shorter
distances between their urinary opening
and their clitoris seen here as the
white bars which appears on the slide as
literal urinary meatus distance or come
D we didn't realize the problem about
the name is Lewis too late then did
women so then did women who did not who
had longer distances between their
clitoral their clitoris and their
urinary Miatas 30 urinary opening and
did not report orgasm with intercourse
so the difference was highly
statistically significant between these
two groups greater than two standard
deviations and the R value for the
combined sample was 0.6 we found that
this anatomical distance was actually
predictive of whether or not a woman had
orgasm with intercourse clearly if our
Anatomy so strongly influences whether
or not she has orgasm with intercourse
with a male that leaves little room for
the genetic quality of the male to
influence the outcome of such
intercourse according to the theorists
the selection pressure of this type of
selection stereo needs to be quite
strong in order to produce any evidence
for would result in terms of selection
thus the anatomical relation we
discovered make such a scenario nearly
completely unfeasible
so the female and truths hypothesis the
only adaptive account being actively
pursued today is facing very substantial
theoretical and empirical hurdles before
it can be accepted as a plausible theory
of female orgasm now let's consider the
fascinating new publish of and vogner
vestige a homolog model in a context of
the other evolutionary explanations for
female orgasm we can see it is different
in several ways first it is not an
occurrence adaptive account and
hypothesizes that the trade is not a
current adaptation does not contribute
to fitness today which conforms very
well with the evidence that we have
today what I noticed most strong is
strikingly and which they discussed is
that the public of an vogner account
concerns only a part or a segment of
female orgasm that is it addresses the
hormonal surges associated with female
orgasm is some of them anyway but not
the characteristic muscular contractions
or spinal reflex which are usually
defining a female orgasm itself this
incomplete aspect of the hypothesis will
need to be addressed in the long run or
else's cannot be considered a full
hypothesis concerning female orgasm but
rather one concerning hormonal surges
upon the occasion a female orgasm itself
thus there is some work left to be done
on the hypothesis in order to make it
complete in this way if so desired let
me characterize then where I see the
evidence today for the vestigial homolog
model now ordinarily on my understanding
ovulation releases a large surge of
luteinizing hormone or LH but they focus
on different hormones namely oxytocin
and prolactin which are released during
orgasm although the research on us a
toasted leaves a lot during orgasm
leaves a lot to be desired for example
it uses four hundred times the naturally
occurring dose of orgasm of oxytocin in
nature one question
is whether there's also a surge of LH
during orgasm in addition the world's
expert in primate sexuality Alan Dixon
has expressed a related word to me in an
email and I share this concern for
looking for increases in prolactin and
spontaneous ovulate errs where according
to public oven vagner hypothesis it
should show up is there evidence for
this dixon despite his encyclopedic
knowledge of primate physiology didn't
know if any now I didn't have room for
this worry on the big slide though so
and I'm unsure about it so it's not
there now these questions highlight as
they recognize how much more research is
needed into female sexuality in both
primates and the mammals in general to
test this hypothesis fully this is one
of my favorite things about the public
Evan Vagner hypothesis expert on a wide
variety of research into traits related
to female sexuality and physiology and
highlights the importance of knowing
about them there is still a question
also raised in correspondence by my
co-author can Wallin concerning the role
of the clitoris specifically whether
reflex ovulation is triggered triggered
by clitoral as they say rather than
cervical stimulation this is also
relevant to the issue of penis
morphology in the species if indeed it
was the clitoris that's important to
reflect ovulation one would expect to
see penis morphology evolved to
stimulate the clitoris inside the vagina
or wherever the clitoris is but instead
only the distal region of the penis
shows a lot of diversity across the
mammals this might indicate that
stimulation of the voltam of the vagina
or and/or the cervix rather than the
clitoris is more likely to be important
in induced ovulation those questions
remain about what the role of the
clitoris really has in ovulation even in
the reflex ovulation cases and this has
consequences for that their hypothesis
as a whole and might need to be
ciated more generally it's very
important to emphasize as public Evan
Vagner themselves do that the female
orgasms hormonal surges are invested or
byproduct of ancient properties of
ovulation whereas the original
by-product views says female orgasm is a
byproduct of male orgasm they both say
that female orgasm is not an adaptation
today nor does that have a biological
function as as was emphasized by vogner
I'm not a believer in deriving social
norms from biological findings whether
there are about adaptations or not but
it's simply a fact that people routinely
do just that in this light the fantastic
bonus account of orgasm as well as the
new vestigial homolog account have
distinct advantages over early accounts
of female orgasm because they expect no
particular adaptive set of responses to
intercourse and thus they privilege none
all winners orgasms are seen as equally
expected and equally normal none are
couched in terms of their superior
functionality as in the bad old days of
masters in Johnson when women who did
not have orgasm with heterosexual
intercourse were called dysfunctional
the two first theories I discussed are
not actively being pursued to my
knowledge today except well the pair
bond making is and we've seen two brave
problems with the female choice model
even though it is actively being pursued
but here we have a brand new theory
involving the deep origins of mammalian
female sexual response one that
highlights the role of the clitoris and
it's stimulation of the hormonal surges
usually accompanying orgasms in some
nearly all applications of evolutionary
biology to the issue of female orgasm
have been problematic half of the
theories offered failed due to andrew
centric assumptions and subsequent
conflicts with the evidence while the
other half are faulty do too sloppy
methodology and also conflict
the six ology finding only to the
fantastic bonus account and the
vestigial the new vestige a homolog
account are currently consistent with
and supported by the available body of
evidence we're very lucky to have such a
fascinating and provocative new
hypothesis to spur on future research
into the evolution of female sexuality
and orgasm thank you very much for your
attention today
I'm over here you're right I just stole
the quicker I don't think that's mine I
mean I I completely agree with your
assessment of that level of empirical
knowledge that is relevant for our model
to be great I completely agree with as
far as we crew to find out nobody asked
whether enthused over laters the
clitoris is actually the sewers of the
neural impulse and that is in principle
in a easily but knowable and but we
don't know it it's implied yes the
ignorance again we don't know but you
know it the way you asked the question
is of course driven by the theory you
have right yes so it's I think that
that's not that's a really nice effect
of having a new theory that we will ask
questions out that you wouldn't
otherwise it's really exactly that's why
I like your theory so much thank you
thank you yeah i have i have 1 1 comment
about the luteinizing hormone not being
present yeah you know you might have
actually not want to have it present
because if you would still be if
luteinizing hormone was present the
orgasm would still cause ovulation that
means the intercourse would would
endanger pregnancy would endanger so
many things so you know it's um yeah so
my goodness I really evolved out of the
picture if that's that's the the way
that you know if our theory is correctly
and I would I would almost predict that
it shouldn't be there
yes yeah yes thank you yeah and another
thing about the morphology of pins we
have actually also discussed with with
with dr. Dixon yes so if so you say that
if the clitoris is somewhere halfway in
the in the vagina for instance yeah and
the penis morphology that changed is
really at the tip of the penis that has
the most variation right yeah so how
does this correlate first I really don't
know the but the the developmental
constraints might be of you know how
much you can vary penile area yeah it is
very but one thing that strikes me is
that of course if the if the clitoris is
at you know at some midway through then
any tip of the of the of the any
morphology that would be changed the tip
would always pass it right well
depending on the thrust right yeah
depending but rather rather than than
having having the trigger at that on the
cervix right depending on the thrust
depending on the thrust if it's a thrust
that is shallow than it would
necessarily simulate it but if it thrust
it deep then it which the relay yeah so
it depends on empirically on this
situation that we don't know again it
highlights what we don't know and and if
there are so many questions that are
raised by your theory that highlight
what we don't know about mammalian and
primate sexuality I think it's such a
terrific theory that raises so many that
highlights all of these questions about
male sexuality of female sexuality pick
male penis structure clitoral structure
all these questions that haven't been
asked before and that we don't have the
answers to because we just don't know
and nobody's investigated it and that's
one reason I think your theory is so
fabulous is that it highlights what we
don't know and it gives an incentive for
people to go ahead and work for the
truth about these things yeah I also
like to your account of the female
choice theory it means that you know by
overcoming this theory it's not only the
woman that is not at all or choice
anymore but it's also you know the mail
gets a massive ated from the need to be
able to cause regard during during
intercourse both you know males and
females are victims of this function mr.
account that they're not label this
pathological or inadequate absolutely
yeah if you're a male and you believe
the female choice there if you're not
going around giving orgasms to all the
women then there's something wrong with
you
could you I'm wondering if anybody could
comment on the anecdotal relationship
between female orgasm during copulation
and pregnancy rates I will yeah um
female let me make sure I have this
straight female female orgasm rates and
pregnancy rates there's no correlation
between female orgasm and pregnancy
rates when it was investigated in fact
and people sought out to discover
whether there was a correlation between
female orgasm and pregnancy rates and
they discovered zero correlation genetic
correlation between pregnancy and
offspring quality and quantity offspring
quantity I correct myself offspring
quantity and female orgasm I'm wondering
if if there's a possibility that both of
those two hypotheses that you mentioned
like if there's some kind of combination
of the two that might be even better
than one of them on its own and how you
might go about you know trying to test
that or if that's even something
anyone's thinking about so if I may so
it's a one unanswered question that we
didn't discuss so if in fact female
orgasm well let's see the physiologic
machinery that underlies
orgasm is a vestige became functionless
then the question is why is still there
right because this teacher characters
tend to get lost or at least very much
reduced in size and occurrence and I
think they are the underlying biology of
the byproduct Theory can help us
understand that because it is still also
in our model correct that there is this
developmental homology between between
the male genitalia and female external
genitalia and so you can make an
argument that mutations that would
further reduce let's say clitoris size
and and all the neuroendocrine machinery
attached to it would have a likely
player tropic effect negative effect on
male sexual performance and reproductive
success so that even a woman that would
have in a mutation reducing her external
genitalia probably would give birth to
sons who themselves would have a lower
fitness and therefore the same mutation
would likely to be get lost right so so
there's the various ways in how these
two hypotheses or the biology underlying
these two ways of thinking about it
connect you to help each other yes I
agree yeah I was wondering about the
characterization of human humans as
spontaneous ovulate errs as opposed to
maybe regular ovulate errs in the
context of like a 28-day cycle as
opposed to induce delegation as it may
I'm right right right but it's not
exactly spontaneous right because it
does happen in a rhythm that's what we
mean yeah I mean its rhythm its
autonomous its its its its internal it
in a pain more than independent of
environment that what it means yeah but
the signal is has to be there
and so the second part to that being
what the distribution of that is across
the great apes in particular our
spontaneous elevator all of all primates
of spontaneous so this transition
happened probably very early in primate
lineage that the transition to
spontaneous are over they shun which
actually also raises the question why do
we still have this orgasmic Machinery
still hanging around but it because how
many million years 50 or whatever BN
years I'm wondering if this questions
for Elizabeth how far back the studies
go that measure the distance that you
were talking about the CU m/d that
distance because it seems like it could
be more of a contemporary problem than
like a problem of our love I guess an
issue that you know generations and
thousands of years or I just want to
know like kind of the temporal
significance of that study yeah our
first dataset is actually from the 1920s
the first data set is from the 1920s the
second data set is from the 1940s so
this wouldn't be a contemporary measure
actually and because we don't believe
there has been a lot of selection on
these measures within the generations
since then we take these as
representative today and we are
interested in encouraging others to do
contemporary measurements and do the
surveys that are necessary to go with
those measurements to determine the
frequency of orgasm with intercourse
thank you
yes so you mentioned muscle contractions
as being a part of every orgasm but
there's a part of orgasms that doesn't
occur every time which is female
ejaculation also known as [ __ ] squirting
and my question is so it at face value
this function seems homologous to the
male anatomy and my question is in the
vestigial homologue model that you're
proposing are there any other animals
that exhibit female ejaculation upon
organs I think we just don't know when
they know a lot about humans because
it's us a little bit about for all 12
monkeys and female physiology of in
copulation has been studied very little
even at all in any most other mammals so
we just don't know you know even how
phylogenetically distributed this you
know reflexive contractions and so
actually are but it's something that
originated long time ago or or not I
mean that would be really important to
know in order to answer the question of
how besides the neuro endocrine function
it via focused on how broad the heritage
from our common ancestors actually is we
just don't have to talk as far as i know
most of most of our most logical data
actually comes from from the books from
that century to century two centuries
ago today yeah hi great talk by the way
um so i noticed in your diagram with the
clitoris as it was moving out that the
vaginal opening was also moving is that
correct so i was wondering if you were
exploring other changes and female
anatomy that were also driving movement
of the clitoris i haven't simply because
the
data is relatively coarse but there is
there is really of that that is that we
are kind of connected to that is working
on changes in female genitalia in in
Florida right Cohen service is now
looking into into specifically the the
the origin it'll sinus and and
development of it so one thing that I
wanted wanted to mention that that I
didn't afterwards the urogenital sinus
in human is that is a normal part of
development so and sometimes actually it
stays around so it's it's really this
this this later change in development
happens in a kind of a similar way as as
it happens in and i will show you home
yeah by tonight yeah I have a question
about Masters and Johnson dr. Lloyd you
mentioned that Masters and Johnson had
talked about some women as dysfunctional
and I wondered if you had any other
critique of Masters and Johnson and also
would any of you like to comment on the
legacy of Masters and Johnson I do have
a critique of Masters and Johnson a very
specific one they set out a normative
process they just they said out of
descriptive process that was also
normative of how sexual response works
in women that described the process of
penetration and response to intercourse
with orgasm for normal women healthy
women and women who didn't respond with
orgasm to this intercourse we're
considered they labeled dysfunctional
they did a lot of measurements on women
have
orgasms with intercourse and studied
them extensively and portrayed these
women as normal but the way they chose
the women for their studies women were
only allowed to be the subjects of their
studies if they reliably had orgasm with
intercourse so these women represented
the way we figure it about eight percent
of women and those were the women that
were studied as representing all women
in sexual response in the Masters and
Johnson study so that's my critique of
Masters and Johnson
I actually have another question um so I
know that concealed ovulation is
something that's very specific to humans
or at least among the great apes and I'm
wondering if there's any relationship
with concealed ovulation and orgasm does
that make any sense or do i need have
asked a little more specifically i mean
i don't i don't see it i have a little
bit of an opinion about the concealed
ovulation though okay I wonder how much
that's a that how much of it it's it's
it's our interpretation by you know
using objective measurements because
there are many studies showing that
females actually act very very different
during the oval ettore time then than
otherwise and that that that is actually
a communication channel that we might
not be capturing by objective
measurements it's obvious that it's not
as obvious and in many other speeches so
that's that's clear but as far as as
correlation with with with orgasms or
induced or type of affectation I don't
know dunno ideological between orgasm
and ovulation there are claims that
women who are ovulating have more
orgasms but it hasn't really been backed
up with any decent studies in general
concealed ovulation is actually not
uniquely human it's the ancestral trait
in the great apes the chimpanzees are
the evolved trade not the ancestral
trait so the advertised ovulation that
you get in chimps is the evolved trait
the ancestral trait is concealed
ovulation so-called concealed ovulation
as was pointed out it's not all that
concealed if you look for subtle cues
but our version of ovulation is the
ancestral trait and not the ax Falls one